die pläne der europäischen organisation
für kernforschung cern für den
nachfolger des weltgrößten
teilchenbeschleunigers large hadron
collider lhc sind wirklich mehr als
beeindruckend der neue collider soll
nicht nur fast viermal so lang werden
wie der lhc sondern auch eine
kollisionsenergie erreichen können die
mehr als siebenmal so groß ist wie der
der finalen ausbaustufe des ltv hier
sollen dann nicht nur neue teilchen
entdeckt werden mit dem ultimativen
futures orkla collider könnte dann
endlich auch aufgeklärt werden woraus
die mysteriöse dunkle materie besteht
und ob es sie gibt alles was er dazu
wissen musst jetzt zwei klicks um
science-fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpassen sie nichts
herzlich willkommen der weltgrößte
teilchenbeschleuniger lhc in genf hat
die physik weit nach vorne gebracht denn
hier wurde 2012 tat explosion
nachgewiesen das letzte noch fehlende
teilchen des standardmodells der
teilchenphysik
doch seitdem verlief die suche nach
neuen teilchen weitestgehend erfolglos
dabei hatte sich die physik welt so sehr
gewünscht mit dem lhc weitere teilchen
jenseits des standardmodells zu sichten
kandidaten für die äußerst mysteriöse
dunkle materie oder aber super
symmetrische teilchen beispielsweise
2026 soll die anzahl der teilchen
kollision pro zeit die so genannte
lumino sieht im lhc noch einmal erhöht
werden so zumindest der plan
doch danach wird der
teilchenbeschleuniger sein potenzial
wohl erschöpft haben und so plant das
cern einen noch größeren collider mit
noch höheren energien den future secure
collider fcc das konzept für den neuen
kleider mit gigantischen ausmaßen wurde
jetzt vorgestellt die fachwelt ist
absolut beeindruckt und das zu recht der
umfang des gigantischen
teilchenbeschleunigers soll 100
kilometern betragen und ist damit nicht
nur fast so breit wie das genfer becken
sondern auch fast viermal so lang wie
der adac in den kreis des
beschleunigerring würde also nicht nur
das genfer stadtgebiet passen sondern
auch noch anteil von frankreich in ihm
wollen forschungsteams dann teilchen
beschleunigen die eine energie von bis
zu 100 tera elektronenvolt erreichen
zum vergleich im lhc beträgt die
kollision
energie derzeit 13 tera elektronenvolt
durch den futures co leiter erhoffen
sich die forschungsteams neue
erkenntnisse zum ixs mechanismus welche
rolle spielt er bei der entstehung des
universums wie interagiert das higgs
boson mit anderen teilchen auf fragen
zur dunklen materie sollen durch den
neuen gigantischen teilchenbeschleuniger
beantwortet werden woraus besteht dunkle
materie
warum gibt es mehr materie als
antimaterie und wie bekommen neutrinos
ihre masse das alles ist also ein
gigantisches wissenschaftliches
experiment oder besser das pikanteste
wissenschaftliche experiment bisher neun
milliarden euro soll der bau laut cern
kosten allein das graben des 100
kilometer langen ringförmigen tunnels in
der nähe des lhc wird wohl alleine fünf
milliarden euro verschlingen laut dem
konzept soll es hier um verschiedene
arten von teilchenkollisionen gehen
zunächst einmal sollen ein beschleuniger
für elektronen positronen kollisionen
gebaut werden so würde die erzeugung von
blue und quarks in einer großen
unübersichtlichen zahl verhindert werden
anders als bei den protonen kollisionen
könnten so tatsächlich präzisere
messungen möglich seien laut plan soll
hier dann mit energien bis zu 360
gigaelektronenvolt gearbeitet werden
dieser beschleunigerring könnte 2040 in
betrieb gehen und etwa 20 jahre lang
spannende erkenntnisse zur elektronen
positronen kollisionen liefert in einem
weiteren schritt soll dann im selben
tunnel ein proton beschleuniger
eingerichtet werden in dem dann
kollisionsenergie von 100
tera-elektronenvolt erreicht werden die
kosten für dieses experiment das produkt
2050 herum starten könnte 15 milliarden
euro
man sieht also das konzept ist echt der
wahnsinn da wundert es nicht dass mehr
als 1300 menschen von 150 verschiedenen
forschungseinrichtungen an ihm getüftelt
haben allerdings ist der bau des
gigantischen teilchenbeschleunigers noch
nicht abgesegnet darüber müssen jetzt
nämlich noch die 22 mitgliedsstaaten des
cern entscheiden es wird auf jeden fall
mega spannend vielleicht werden wir
endlich erfahren ob es die dunkle
materie wirklich gibt oder auf eine neue
physik stoßen über die ja schon lange
spekuliert wird die stringtheorie
nachgewiesen werden und so weiter und so
fort dass es
extrem spannend wie immer wie wir immer
weiter in den mikrokosmos vordringen und
dort eine wirklich paradoxe welt
entdecken die ganz und gar anders ist
als unsere erlebte realität verrückt
aber es geht auch in die andere richtung
in den makrokosmos wenn er auf dieses
video klickt die fundamentale bedeutung
der raumfahrt vor neugier zone wie immer
top spannend also auf jeden fall ansehen
und abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran